Looks like the Senate Democrats
are going to Liz War!
During the debate over
Keebler elf Jeff Sessions,
-who was just confirmed...
-(laughter)
Same guy.
-Prove me wrong.
-(applause and cheering)
...was just confirmed
as attorney general today.
America's Aunt Elizabeth Warren
read a 30-year-old letter
by Coretta Scott King
denouncing Sessions.
-But apparently,
that historic... -MAN: Great!
Yeah, apparently,
that historical...
I know. Like, two people,
-and the rest of them
are like, "Aah." -(laughter)
-"I mean, I could
do this, but..." -(laughter)
Apparently, that historical burn
was too hot for the Senate.
Republicans claimed she was
"impugning another Senator"
and silenced her.
People like Betsy DeVos
chimed in with,
-"What does 'impugn' mean?"
-(laughter and groaning)
-So... Warren...
-(applause and cheering)
-Yeah!
-HARDWICK: Yeah.
-Take 'em down!
-Yeah.
So, Warren went outside,
read the letter live
on Facebook Live,
right between a live feed of
a dude's trip to the DMV
and probably a video of a
chinchilla licking its balls.
-(laughter)
-Twitter immediately
exploded with the hashtags
#ShePersisted,
#LetLizSpeak and #LetLizTalk,
because they support
a woman's right
to choose everything
-except for one hashtag.
-(laughter)
By the way, I don't know
how they missed the hashtag
#LizLemonParty.
That would of been great.
-(laughter) -But you know why?
'Cause she's... -Yeah!
-Yeah! -Because it's a...
-(applause and cheering)
You have to look
at what's happened.
She's interrupting
a room full of old white guys
jerking each other off.
I mean, it fits so perfectly.
-(laughter)
-JEN KIRKMAN: Ah.
And thanks to all the publicity,
her Facebook Live
got over seven million views,
instead of the seven
it would have gotten on C-SPAN.
-(laughter) -Including
her three grandkids. Now,
all this started
because Elizabeth Warren
was supposedly mean to Sessions,
but, comedians...
(whining):
She was all mean to Sessions!
But we're not bound
by decorum here on @midnight.
We're not on the Senate floor,
so go ahead, impugn
-a politician! Anyone?
-Yeah.
-Jen Kirkman.
-Okay.
Donald Trump is so dumb
that he called
a retired lieutenant
at 3:00 in the morning
'cause he didn't know
if the dollar was strong,
and then, when the guy was like,
"That's not my area,"
he got mad and hung up.
-Um...
-(laughter)
-Points.
-But he actually did that!
-(applause)
-That's not a joke. -Yeah.
-He actually did that.
-HARDWICK: Want to know if I...
-(applause and cheering)
-Is it still okay to give you
points, 'cause that...
you didn't make that up?
Nick Swardson.
Bernie Sanders went as a scrotum
for Halloween and no makeup.
-(laughter and groaning)
-HARDWICK: Points.
-Points.
-(applause)
-Paul Feig.
-Mike Pence is gay.